I take Ambien to go to sleep my doctor
goes you're much better off healthwise
never taking those sleeping pills ever
again and having a glass of wine at
night time before you go to sleep
smoking your weed and I go what it's my
doctor at this point I thought I
couldn't sleep without them pills right
I go okay can you just write me one more
prescription for those I just want to go
to sleep and need to go all right he
writes it to me and I go to the pharmacy
and I go here's my prescription they
bring it back to me and the bottle has
one pillow I shake it up and I go hey
this is bull I there's only one you go
this is what you're doctor so the next
night I started backing the wine and the
next checkup I went to my blood pressure
is perfect thank you very much